bonjour tout le monde et ben voilà ravis
de commencer cette série vidéo sur les
joueurs français célèbre et du coup j'ai
pensé faire une approche un peu
historique à travers l'histoire et donc
débuté par par phildar mon fils d'or
j'espère que vous connaissez c'était
c'était juste le meilleur joueur
français est même le meilleur joueur du
monde ou au xviiie siècle dont fil d'or
est né en 1726 mort en 1795 et il a
juste archi dominé son époque
donc il jouait très souvent au café de
la régence celle avoue finalement tous
les joueurs d'échecs à l'époque se
rejoignaient pour jouer disputer des
parties et ses terrains et il a été
connu là bas il a fait de nombreuses
reconnaissances et voilà donc les jeux
contre à peu près tout le monde et il
était juste vraiment beaucoup plus fort
et même à tel point qu'ils devaient
carrément je veux des parties handicap à
un moment de sa carrière pour un peu
équilibré les débats
voilà donc c'est aussi un nom très connu
philidor pourquoi parce que les laisser
son nom pour l'ouverture fise art qui
est bas qui est celle là en fait je vous
dis 6 pour défendre le pian il pensa
fille dort je sens que c'était bien de
jouer des six pour défendre le pion pour
garder le pion à l'option eps vii pour
pouvoir éventuellement je vais kf5 est
attaqué le centre blanc
voilà ça ça paraît résister à l'épreuve
du temps mais
mais bon voilà en tout cas ce qu'il
avait vraiment compris et cette phrase
est restée de lui c'est les pions sont
l'âme des échecs et pourquoi ça a
simplement fait ce qu'il veut dire c'est
oui la structure pions et c'est
important il ya bien compris
l'importance des majorités et ouais de
pousser les pions et les pièces derrière
c'est comme ça c'était c'était son truc
quoi est il était hyper en avance sur
son temps déjà très stratège et il est
peut-être même deux siècles davance
limite quoi donc voilà il avait écrit un
livre qui s'appelait la mise du jeu
d'échecs et à côté de ça c'est aussi un
très bon compositeur de musique voilà
vous passez par les lui juste comme ça
on va regarder une première partie qu'il
a joué donc ils avaient les noirs contre
joueur se plaît monsieur van brûle voilà
voilà donc bah on va s'y attacher
donc 4 il est noir il joue aux cinq
comme bien souvent et son adversaire je
vous fous ces quatre ne tombe pas dans
le piège de chevaux et cavaliers
3 parce que phildar pensais que c'était
limite douteux des qualifs trois causes
de décès comme on a dit parce que
ensuite f5 arrive et les noirs attaque
le centre blanc mais fausse et quatre au
moins ça va ça évite le piège c6
intéressant donc il tout de suite
prendre le centre hélas son adversaire
et vite en faisant d'un jeu de bien sûr
pourquoi ça et vite parce que sur un
dessin qui ferait plus on prend et après
la prise du rayon de 5 en mer
mais bien sûr donc il ne fait pas des
six dessins qui fait des six les blancs
ont fait ces trois pour jouer des 4es
philidor donc sa stratégie
un petit beau miroir f5 attaque ce pion
donc avec une attention plus tard de
prendre le contrôle du centre par par
des 5 alors f5 ça peut avoir l'air un
peu risqué voire 2 bis rue des potiers
francs g8 est comme ça surtout reprendre
les dommages 5
donc c'est pas faux ça fait échec ça
attaque le pion à vii
mais à vrai dire pas très bon pour les
blancs parce que les noirs frégé 6 et
sur d'un prince sept tours j'ai cette
attaque adam la dame bouge alors peu
importe qu'ils sont là et puis on prend
2,4 du coup les marins regagner leur
furent moins mais ben on voit qu'ils ont
un énorme centre de pions sur tout le
monde et peut continuer à avancer
les blancs c'est un peu pénible que ce
guerrier du mal à se développer un
magazine très contrôlé celui-là est et
si gêné parce que les caisses c3 est
prise et du coup ça vous va sortir donc
un gros problème pour développer côté
blanc alors c'est pour ça que sur f5
transit marchait pas trop des bleus ont
fait des trois pour protéger le centre
ok donc mais n'en fait qu'à 6 il a fait
pions pro f 5 actuellement cavaliers f3
ici était
mamane peut-être logique pour garder le
centre pas le rendre comme ça mais bon
admettons vous prend qu'à des quatre
attaques centre hockey ou quatre rouges
et 5 et des saintes donc bien de la part
de philidor qui en fait blocks diagonale
on sait qu'on me touche au plus bref
c'est quand même une vie banale
surveiller donc voilà gagne est en train
de four le chou bouge et food et 6 il se
développe tout va bien qui est le cas et
et si on fait un premier bilan dès
maintenant on voit que la position noir
et qu'un meilleur puisque le
développement est quasiment terminée il
ya plus qu'à rauque et toutes les pièces
jours on a une belle chaîne de pions qui
va de b 7e 4 et voilà pour les blancs
c'est pas si simple de terminer le
développement
alors il a fait h3 bon admettons h6
foule trois dames sautoir peinture
appliquée très bien mesdames et why not
et les blancs font un f4 alors f4
pourquoi
bah il veut faire en fait damer f2 et
qui avaient lieu deux pour arriver à se
développer
donc on peut comprendre après le défaut
de f4 à long terme envers dans la partie
c'est que ça donne ce qu'ils ont passé
eux au noir qui va du coup voilà il est
là il menacera tout le long et mettre à
surveiller comme le lait sur le feu quoi
c'est un peu le mbp de la position et
voilà et sinon aussi plus plus tactique
on va dire donc moins stratège mais qui
était très fort c'était seulement de
prendre place en lice
c'est un souci parce que sur l'écologie
cavalli prend les noirs peuvent eux qui
voyagent 5 et donc le souci c'est qu'on
menace kg 3 fourchettes
il y avait des f1 défend mais on veut
faire petit rat est là le problème pour
les blancs secs sur disons grand roque
est normal pour quelques chinois il ya
cavalière 4 qui arrive donc là vous
prendrez vos cibles adam et dernière
donc faudrait bouger la dame mais parce
que si on enlève 2 ou 1 on se prend la
fourchette on va devoir donner la
qualité et si on fait d'amener 2 c'est
la même en cavale et là le roi doit
bouger en face du fou on va se prendre
une découverte et partent beaucoup de
matériel donc à vrai dire sur f4 la
prise en passant était vraiment très
forte et j'ai franchement position très
difficile pour les mains j'étais
sûrement un gars rapides pour les noirs
mais philidor non je vais plus
positionnelle qui l'a pas vu tout ça il
a joué il a joué cinq personnes pourquoi
il veut éviter g4 donc on peut
comprendre il faut stopper un peu la
majorité adverse les blongios et 4 il a
joué à si bon qu'il veut mange mange on
comprend à 6 plus tard pourquoi d'un f2
petit rock qui avaient lieu deux et donc
l'explication de la 6c qui oblige les
baies 5 et ce qu'est vanilla le recycler
verser 4 une belle case
ok donc écouter les blancs aux rockets
qu'avait libye 6 maintenant kg 3 et là
un coup peut être que de tout
différemment une adjugée 6 pour défendre
le flou et
il a une bonne
il veut se donner une bonne structure
pions après ce qui était possible de
faire éventuellement c'était simplement
de repartir avec le flou sa valeur quand
même bien aussi mais ok il faisait ici
s'il veut pas que les blancs puisse
faire f 5 vous qu'on s'active et alors
tour à ses 1 était joué et il est venu
bloquer kelly c4 alors maintenant il ya
eu quelques problèmes cinq pions pour un
f5 d'alger 3 d'alger cette dame prend
dame roi prend dame fo prend ses quatre
dépensé 4 donc en présence comme ça ils
se donnent la colonne b ce qui ce qui
est bien attaquer le plan b 2 et est
donc les blonds stu arriérés à ce qu'un
petit souci et on voit en fait un truc
qui pour moi m'a un peu surprise c'est
que philidor
ça ressemble pas partie romantique en
fait on est vite devoir de rands hersen
ou deux joueurs comme ça qui veut tout
pour l'attaqué gambie finalement lui
rend dans une petite finale et ensemble
un jeu technique vraiment en avance sur
son temps bien qu à lui j'ai trois
jouets bon pourquoi pas à défendre un
peu ses pions battoir b vite sur la
colonne donc mon avis on tape sur le
pion les blancs ont fait b3 il fait
froid 3 très bien gagner en tempo
désolidarisant que les lits tour en
course et de il faut parce que si on
faisait un couteau bien lier à ces trois
organisations de cavaliers y enseigne qu
il va et après il y aura un ces dossiers
1 qui pour arriver mais bon déjà lequel
il serait perdue donc nouveau khalife et
or ces deux prises en b3 et il prend du
pion un peu étrange peut-être une
décision sûrement du cannabis puis
logique parce que ce pion à 2 ne serait
pas en b3 ou il est quand même beaucoup
plus faible et accessible points noirs
donc ouais un peu bizarre de prendre 2 à
1 lors du tour ces huit jouer et il a
échangé les tours à leur tour ado serait
possible mais
je pense puis villa est prévu pour ces
trois ça va beaucoup ressembler la
partie donc on va aller directement allé
voir la partie et voilà la même occasion
il a changé les tours et toi un full
méca de jouer du coup il prend option à
6 mais maintenant pour cette fois du
coup on attaque ce fou qui qui peut pas
vraiment reculer parce que on se prend
la fourchette donc il faut le défendre
9 2 est maintenant tourné trois logiques
on attaque à deux le caïd haineux qui
défendent et b3 donc on va regagner
tokyo - et et d'autres en ce moment une
bonne position
voilà on a cette finale maintenant avec
avec cavaliers contre mauvais fou
quelque part quand même le pion passé on
voit que c'est pas mal celui donc on a
déjà dit il est passé alors que nous et
nos deux pions on immobilise un peu ces
trois pions blancs
donc il n'y a pas vraiment de majorité
et une majorité mais n'est pas elle
n'est pas vraiment mobile et donc les
blancs fait tour c'est de maintenant
donc pourquoi pas rentrer sur la colonne
s'est maintenant il va directement
prendre le taureau par les cornes on va
dire il fait h théâtre il veut casser la
chaîne de pions pourrait venir sont
prendre plus bref on voit revenir à un
peu tactique prêt si jamais ils
pouvaient un plan que j'aimerais bien
aller à faire ce qu'ils valent et 8
caïds et 6-4
mais il est vrai que si on s'en va avec
le cavalier les blancs ont peut-être
fait retour ces cinq on n'a pas trop le
temps de mettre ça en place
alors il a fait il a fait h4 you tour
c'est cet échec roi rouge et il a pris
maintenant h4 et qu'elle alliage 5 alors
là ça menace qu'elles voudront pas
pareil mais on faire autre chose c'est
qu'elle prend pions puisque sur flu
prend il veut faire tous rêvent trois
échecs attaque le roi et le fou qui sera
henri iv à noter qu ciblant des rois eux
deux il y aura kg 3 le roi doit revenir
à f2 bien sûr parce que s'ils vendaient
de vie se prennent la fourchette dans le
croate 2 mais à ce moment là qu'est la
fin quand même s'il reprend tout reprend
on va tomber dans la finale deux tours
où on va pouvoir reprendre ses pions ou
celui là
et s'ils prennent pas
le flou faut le recul est loin mais bon
le familia thorax 3 qui va concept bien
placé quoi et et petit à petit on va
encore attaquer les pions externe donc
donc au final pour 17 le pouget par les
blancs pourquoi pas donc il a fait son
calibre un efficace vous prend tout un
chèque à bouge dans un f4 et et tout
reprend des 5
donc on a les deux pions passé billet
ici et les blancs des pions un peu
séparés alors faut dire que si les
blancs défendent bien l'un des deux est
nul mais on va voir phyllida en fait
pareil bon feeling de la position au
lieu d'aller prendre son pion là qui
sert à rien à vrai dire il joue ton rêve
3 pour le pont culture des huit pourquoi
pas et il joue tour des trois tours
derrière le pion passé déjà bon
placement sexe et c'est la chose à faire
mais bon il lui avait pas de livres à
lire et les pas de ta bulle base de
choses comme ça et déjà comprendre ça
c'est bien
et de deux la tour fausse une action
horizontale relation horizontale à
l'action verticale très bien placé dans
les blancs à l'option les noirs aussi il
fait des six échecs montrent maintenant
qu'il a fait sa petite baraque et de
pions très bien jouer et de faire échec
le roi va devoir redescendre sur la
première rangée et roy haynes est mon
fils bien quand même s'occuper un peu de
soutien
or la suit les blongios 5 et je pense
ici rate le coche parce que il aurait pu
trouver un moyen de faire nul en jouant
17 17 le truc c'est que sur trois en
clair logis karine warnault le contenu
des cuves 3 créer un réseau de maths et
avancer leurs pions les blancs avaient
fait retour huit comme ça surtout
reprend 17 alors tour ici et blanc
allaient regagner
elle a regagné le pion et donc on en est
là à voir une finale mais il n'a raté le
coche la tâche 5 à l'aigle enfants de
trois et il fait acheter ici pousse à
fond mais pas trop tard en fait les
blancs pour f3 est là y'a plus rien à
faire puisque les blancs et les noirs
pendant que mal à se battre on voit les
pions là qu'ils prennent toutes les
cases du roi et silence des rois le vin
il y aurait f2 endroit bouge tour échec
et dames à suivre voilà donc bah bonne
victoire technique on va dire de
philidor mails même si ce n'était pas
une partie ultra spectaculaire on voit
qu'il avait posé les bases d'un jeu
positionnelle qui comprenait bien et et
voilà donc été très en avance sur son
temps et c'était clairement le le
meilleur joueur de son temps allez on se
retrouve donc bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures d'autres parties de phildar et
aussi je vous montrerai un peu des
finales qu'il est théorisé voilà allez à
bientôt